hey everyone silver adhere and welcome
to a very special teaser for a new ride
that'll make an appearance in planet
coaster I'm not going to show it quite
yet but if you're up for a challenge I'd
like to invite you to guess what kind of
coaster I'm talking about now for
starters I can say that a lot of coaster
enthusiasts have been waiting on this
one not that I've done any empirical
research per se it's just that it's one
of the most well known and recognized
designs in the industry and even if
you're not a coaster enthusiasts chances
are that you've been on one of these
either in a theme park or in some kind
of fairground and it may even have been
your first coaster to go upside down
because this thing right here is a true
classic
in fact I'm talking about the first ever
coaster type in history to feature a
vertical loop in version one we can now
find all around the globe and which
remains iconic until this day despite
how old it is it's a flexible design
that comes in all shapes and sizes from
launched shuttle coasters to regular old
lift Hill based layouts but one thing
they all share is their signature
circular loop now the coaster type that
this ride is based on was invented by a
man called untold Schwarzkopf please
excuse my German pronunciation there but
man now I'm sure that many of you will
know what I'm talking about anyway I am
really glad that this kind of coaster
made it into the game it's one of my
favorite coaster types and to be honest
I know that I as well as quite a few
others have been asking for this for
quite a while now and I can safely say
that it looks just like its real-life
counterpart so with that all said the
coaster is going to be called the SLV
supposedly it was named after me and you
can get it in the new magnificent rides
collection
[Music]